welcome to Hannity tonight it is clear
you the American people elected a winner
three years the Russia collusion hoax
nine months of commis corrupt illegal
fishing expedition and two years of
Muller's
hyper partisan witch hunt months of the
Schumer ship sham show and now actual
real acquittal exoneration vindication
the president remains totally unfazed in
fact he's winning like never before his
agenda is a massive success as we saw on
Tuesday night look at this a brand new
Gallup poll finding 90% of Americans are
satisfied with their personal life I
hope to one day make it a hundred
economic confidence is that the highest
point since the year 2000 president
Trump racking up accomplishments at a
record-setting pace his approval numbers
by the way look at this better than ever
before this despite the fact and watch
these success the exact opposite of the
bite in Obama years facing more undue
rage and resistance frankly than any
president in history watch this we've
been going through this now for over
three years
it was evil it was corrupt it was dirty
cops
it was leakers and Liars
and this should never ever happen to
another president ever we went through
hell unfairly did nothing wrong did
nothing wrong I've done things wrong in
my life I will admit not purposely but
I've done things wrong but this is what
the end result is
every time I'd say this is unfair let's
go to court they say so you can't go to
court this is politics
and we were treated unbelievably
unfairly and you have to understand we
first went through Russia Russia Russia
it was all alright as you can see one of
the president's greatest strengths his
ability to be serious and yet in spite
of all of this actually extremely funny
given the nonstop history of the left
that you need to have a sense of humor
to stay sane these days today we saw a
perfect example of this during his
remarks about Minority Whip Steve
Scalise remember he was fatally he was
not fatal he was shot nearly fatally by
that far left maniac in 2017 watch this
a man who's braver than me and braver
than all of us in this room he got he
got wet he got whacked my Steve Wright I
went to the hospital with our great
first lady that night right honey and we
saw a man that was not gonna make it he
was not gonna make it he was the doctor
and I told him his wife I said she loves
you why do you say that
because she was devastated a lot of
wives wouldn't give a damn it really
looked like he had a 20-25 percent
chance I think you set a record for
blood loss and Steve Scalise I actually
honestly I think you're better looking
now you're more handsome now you you
weren't that good looking you look good
now you are a warrior Steven is
fantastic and the president Thanks so
many other people that went to war for
him throughout all of these witch hunts
all of these lies and conspiracy
theories through every hoax through
every slander smear besmirched and
Scalise will join us in just a moment
without a doubt he's been a key figure
in the fight against Pelosi's radical
revenge focused agenda in the house
tonight that agenda again utterly
failing what have they done for we the
American people look at this the
editorial board Wall Street Journal
calling policies impeachment sham a
quote sorry period in congressional
history constitutional scholar Jonathan
Turley he didn't vote for Donald Trump
calling on her to resign he's right on
Tuesday a very angry Nancy Pelosi
staging this nationally televised
non-stop temper tantrum and what is a
petty small petulant display of this
rage the psychosis of motion remember
Nancy Pelosi ripping up the President's
speech calling it all a pack of lies
reality by the way plus he apparently
was planning this stunt all along in
fact look at your screen Pelosi actually
he was like pre ripping each of the
pages that she actually took the time to
prep the rip and she planned the whole
thing obviously and as you can see here
she even tested the ripped ability of
the document during the speech look at
look at this right there
oh I guess we know why Petie Pelosi was
so distracted and it was weird and
distracting and mumbling and I'm like
okay I got a I got a not focus on that
part of the show because I wanted to
hear the address she was doing at the
whole address preparing for the big show
she was planning after the president's
address I remember this is a very same
Pelosi claiming that she doesn't hate
the president no she's so prayerful
about it all in so somber this morning
the president he had this to say about
Pelosi's prayers and he's dead on
accurate
listen courageous Republican politicians
and leaders had the wisdom fortitude and
strength to do what everyone knows was
right I don't like people who use their
faith as justification for doing what
they know is wrong nor do I like people
who say I pray for you when they know
that that's not so petty Pelosi prepped
the rip Wow
those remarks at the National Prayer
Breakfast warrant Joe's targeting Pelosi
also senator MIT Romney this week Romney
saying that his deep faith led him to
vote to convict the president and by the
way he exonerated acquit and Pro and
quote Joe and zero Experian
Hunter in the same point at the same
time okay MIT whatever you say liberal
Morning Joe praising Romney's higher
calling fake news Jim Acosta
that's right calling it a Profile in
Courage wopo resident far left tack
Jennifer Rubin writing Romney is a man
of uncommon decency and honor the media
mob fawning all over Romney all day now
I recall it really wasn't that long ago
that that same media mob was falsely
accusing Romney let's see being racist
the sexist the misogynist the tax cheat
and the felon Wow Romney Pierre defecto
your new friends just a reminder once
again mid stepped in it calling Russia
our number one geopolitical enemy what's
this the evil empire again you also have
our every every morning it's going to be
the joke that keeps on giving
can he relate to working women you know
it made it sound almost like working
women are some mail-order product one
huge explosive word out there just
incendiary victims it was a
condescending unbelievably insensitive
way of insulting people by calling them
all victims these are the people Romney
now trust his new friends and not the
people who steadfastly defended him from
these false attacks for so many years
Romney of all people
well you've diminished your self met sad
it's tragic and you should have known
that the truth means nothing to the
media mob and their partners in the
Democratic Party that now love you their
smears their lies their conspiracy
theories they're never ending and by the
way now you are part of it really you
don't think quid and pro and quo Joe
you're not getting the billion until you
fire the prosecutor investigating my
zero experience son being paid millions
you just exonerated them Wow good for
you meant you're really consistent you
think this charade is over now that the
president has been acquitted hate to
tell you think again watch this the
president has been acquitted by the
United States Senate double jeopardy
does not apply in politics Nancy Pelosi
in her house Jerry Nadler saying today
the chairman of the Judiciary they're
gonna sip
quina john bolton that's risky for the
democrats it is risky because it's
t-ball for Trump politically to say this
is gratuitous this is all political but
but it's also risky for all these
senators who just voted on the
president's side as this new information
comes out so you're we should pause and
reflect on the history of today in the
context of impeachment this is over but
it's not over no Jeff will you do it
again
just keep doing it it never ends which
home will continue the house will
probably try to impeach the president
over and over and over again as we speak
they're actually planting let's bring in
John Bolton okay now hang on a second
even they bring in John let's say the
president said to John Paul you know
what I'm gonna I'm not giving them the
money unless they do this this and this
the four facts never change do they
ambassador they never changed they never
did anything they never felt pressure to
to do anything and even more importantly
when you look at the tape of Joe Biden
in the interview a hunter Biden with no
experience the amount of money that's
it's a prima facie case of corruption
president also has a sworn duty as we
have said from the beginning to
faithfully execute the laws and that
Ukrainian election interference stuff
separate and apart from the Russia
interference yeah that would be if you
recall not January 11 2017 two political
investigation and a Ukrainian court said
Ukraine interfered in the 2016 election
to help Hillary and they were successful
Politico told us wow that would be
faithfully executing the laws you got a
corrupt congenital compromise liar by
the name of Adam Schiff already plotting
his neck top secret style hearings now
for you we the American people 271 days
guess what you are the ultimate jury you
will be able you all with an opportunity
to shock the world again and by the way
and reelect this president who has
accomplished all the things we put on
the screen now if you want all of this
to end I have an answer when you vote
for Donald Trump you have the all the
power I only have one little vote in New
York you can also give the house back to
the Republican Party a Republican
majority for the president and you can
vote for Republican senators in your
state while you're voting
for president Trump the witch hunt will
then stop and then the country will move
forward and imagine this president
actually being able to work without
never-ending witch-hunts lies conspiracy
hoaxes misinformation disinformation
every day Wow amazing what we can
accomplish without that hovering over
his head every second of every minute of
every hour of every day and as the
president said during his State of the
Union address the best is yet to come
how great is it 13 million more
Americans food stamps eight million more
poverty under Obama Louis labor
participation rate in the 70s 8 million
fewer Americans on food stamps nearly 8
million new jobs millions out of poverty
the best employment situation for every
demographic in the country in 50 years
Wow we could do more good news for the
president's re-election bid that is the
Democratic Party is a trainwreck in
every aspect the same people that want
to take over your health care and give
you no choice in health care and control
every major industry in the US it could
even count a few thousand votes in the
state of Iowa now the official tally
delayed for several days finally they
got to a hundred percent they just did
moments ago so riddled with errors and
inaccuracies the DNC chair is calling
for an immediate recanvass okay let's
continue that Iowa caucus shift show if
you will but don't worry Democrats know
who to blame for the dumpster fire in
Iowa I had any evidence yep they are
blaming including congresswoman Sheila
Jackson Lee Russia and Trump others are
blaming President Trump if the dog bites
the beast things you're feeling sad it's
got to be Donald Trump's fall right by
the way you drink too much Jack Daniels
a beer you don't feel good the next
morning it's not their fault or your
fault
see trump's fault report claiming that
some supporters might have actually
called into an iowa democratic hotline
and clogged up the calls this is a
conspiracy the russians told trump to do
it and by the way Trump might actually
give Alaska to Russia so that Russia
helps them in the 2020 election Schiff
said that and of course Democrats this
debacle will pale in comparison
the looming inter-party civil war oh oh
look at a Rob Bernie again the
Democratic establishment once again
trying to rig the primary against him
we need Donna Brazile come back and tell
that story that phone call she had to
make saying yeah it all happened Bernie
ultimately none of it will matter
ultimately you are the ultimate jury you
know I know
we're smelly Walmart shoppers guilty yep
I cling to God I believe in God a
creator I really do our Constitution
Second Amendment rights I believe in the
Bible I believe in religion I'm an
irredeemable deplorable and Walmart I
saved money at I like Walmart